en este vídeo vamos a mostrar que si
tomamos un triángulo cualquiera estoy
aquí va a ser un triángulo arbitrario el
que nosotros querramos entonces siempre
podemos pensar a este triángulo como el
triángulo medial de otro triángulo es
decir podemos construir otro triángulo
de tal forma que los puntos medios de
sus lados sean estos tres vértices bueno
para hacer esto vamos a empezar trazando
una paralela a este segmento que pase
por este vértice de acá más o menos no
nos va a quedar algo de este estilo y
eso siempre podemos hacerlo siempre
podemos trazar la paralela a un segmento
que pase por un punto dado bueno tan
solo al trazar está paralela vemos que
empiezan a suceder cosas interesantes
con los ángulos
por ejemplo este ángulo de acá y este
ángulo de acá son alternos internos con
estas paralelas y está transversal
entonces deben de ser ángulos iguales y
de manera similar este ángulo que voy a
marcar con dos marquitas en color
naranja es alterno interno con este de
acá
en esta transversal y estas dos
paralelas de esta forma estos dos son
ángulos iguales vale bueno déjame déjame
nada más marcar aquí que estas son
paralelas para que no se nos olvide y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es repetir la
construcción de los otros dos lados
entonces ahora déjame trazar déjame
trazar una recta paralela a este
segmento que pase por este punto de acá
entonces más o menos nos va a quedar
algo de este estilo más o menos algo así
vale de tal forma que esa sea paralela a
este segmento de aquí lo voy a indicar
con dos flechitas con dos fechas y otra
vez vamos a empezar a pasar ángulos
entonces observa este ángulo naranja
ahora es ángulo correspondiente de este
ángulo de acá con esta transversal
transversal de las paralelas azules de
manera similar
tenemos que este ángulo este ángulo es
alterno interno con este de acá con las
paralelas azules y esta transversal rosa
bueno y además este ángulo que no he
marcado que lo voy a poner
tres marquitas en rosa es alterno
interno con este de acá y por lo tanto
son iguales es alterno interno
considerando considerando las paralelas
azules y esta transversal que ahorita
está blanca bueno déjame terminar la
construcción para el tercer lado
entonces ahora vamos a tomarnos una
paralela a este segmento que pase por
este vértice de acá más o menos algo
algo de este estilo vale y otra vez
vamos a empezar a pasar ángulos esta de
acá es paralela a esta de acá para estar
acá de esta forma tenemos que este
ángulo rosa este ángulo rosa es alterno
interno considerando esta transversal y
estas paralelas naranjas entonces sería
igual a este ángulo de acá luego tenemos
que este ángulo rosa es correspondiente
con este ángulo rosa considerando la
paralela azul las paralelas azules y la
transversal naranja y finalmente déjame
pasar déjame pasar el ángulo azul a
algunos lados entonces este ángulo azul
es alterno interno con este de acá
considerando las paralelas azules y
letras
rosa y finalmente uff esto es muy
cansado este ángulo es ángulo
correspondiente de este de acá de este
de acá considerando las paralelas rosas
y la transversal naranja muy bien ya
acabamos de pasar ángulos pero ahora
vemos que sucede algo bien interesante
al hacer esta construcción
automáticamente nos construimos cuatro
triángulos que tienen sus tres ángulos
iguales entonces todos esos triángulos
son semejantes entre sí eso es algo muy
interesante y de hecho vamos a probar
que no sólo son semejantes sino que
además son triángulos congruentes
por ejemplo déjame tomar el color
naranja y ver este este triángulo de
aquí con este triángulo de acá
observemos que tienen el ángulo azul
este lado naranja que comparten y el
ángulo rosa ángulo azul lado naranja y
ángulo rosa entonces por el criterio
ángulo
ángulo estos dos triángulos de aquí son
congruentes bueno ahora vamos con estos
dos de acá vamos a marcar con con dos
rayitas así a esta longitud a la
longitud del lado azul y veamos que
también tienen ángulo rosa lado azul
ángulo naranja en común aquí también es
ángulo rosa lado azul ángulo naranja y
por lo tanto estos dos triángulos son
congruentes y finalmente podemos repetir
el argumento aquí abajo es básicamente
lo mismo es la misma idea otra vez
tenemos ángulo azul lado rosa ángulo
naranja ángulo azul lado rosa ángulo
naranja así que de nuevo por el criterio
ángulo lado ángulo estos dos de aquí
estos dos de aquí son triángulos
congruentes entonces todos los
triángulos son congruentes al central y
por lo tanto todos son congruentes entre
sí pero eso nos permite pasar un montón
de longitudes por ejemplo tenemos esta
que marque así con tres rayitas
pero esta es correspondiente con esta de
acá en estos dos triángulos congruentes
y por lo tanto estas dos longitudes son
iguales
de manera similar estos dos triángulos
son congruentes y por lo tanto este
segmento es congruente con este y este
también mide tres rayitas
así que ya empiezan a suceder cosas más
interesantes todavía este punto que
todavía no había nombrado digamos y
resulta ser el punto medio de este
segmento que se forma por estos vértices
no sé déjame llamarles
y f para entonces ya nos conseguimos que
a fuera a punto medio d
efe bueno de manera similar este punto
ve este punto b va a ser el punto medio
de que digamos
efe de df de cómo le hacemos para ver
eso pues esta longitud es congruente a
esta longitud porque son longitudes
correspondientes en estos triángulos
congruentes esta miden dos rayitas de
manera similar ésta mide dos rayitas por
la convivencia de estos dos y así ve es
el punto medio de fd y finalmente a este
punto de acá que le voy a llamarse
también lo vamos a poder pensar como un
punto medio aquí hay que pasar las
longitudes naranjas esta es
correspondiente con esta en los
triángulos congruentes y ésta es como un
respondiente con esta de acá en los
triángulos congruentes de modo que es de
c es igual a c y así se es punto medio
de d
muy bien entonces esto prueba la
afirmación que dije al inicio la
afirmación que yo dije es que siempre
que tenemos un triángulo dado un
triángulo
dado un triángulo abc siempre podemos
encontrar otro triángulo lado abc
podemos podemos encontrar encontrar
digamos un triángulo d
efe triángulo d efe de modo de modo que
que el triángulo abc abc es triángulo
medial medial medial de el triángulo de
efe entonces esto está bien interesante
por sí mismo pero a lo mejor tú tienes
ganas de saber más y de decir bueno esto
está padrísimo y luego que bueno luego
viene algo todavía más padre ahí te va
la siguiente idea ahora imaginemos que
tomamos las alturas del triángulo a b c
vale entonces vamos a tomarnos
vamos a tomarnos esta altura de acá aquí
llega a un ángulo
ángulo recto más o menos algo de este
estilo vamos a tomarnos esta de acá y
vamos a tomarnos de esta de acá bueno si
te das cuenta ahorita las dibuje y todas
pasan por un mismo punto estas son
alturas y dibujé las dibuja de tal forma
que todas pasarán por un mismo punto
pero eso es algo que todavía no hemos
demostrado no sabemos si realmente las
tres alturas pasan siempre por un mismo
punto bueno pues vamos a utilizar este
hecho que probamos al inicio del vídeo
para mostrar que en efecto las alturas
de un triángulo siempre pasan por un
mismo punto o sea las tres pasan por un
mismo punto vale bueno pues vamos a
hacer lo siguiente lo que vamos a hacer
es pensar en esta altura en la altura
por a y cómo interactúa con el triángulo
d
efe
observa que aquí tenemos un ángulo recto
pero ya habíamos dicho que las dos
rectas rosas serán paralelas entonces
estoy aquí es un ángulo recto que es
alterno interno con este de acá con este
de acá y éste también está eternizando
con este de acá de esta forma la altura
del triángulo es perpendicular al lado
efe
pero y esto es la cosa que es muy
importante no solo es perpendicular sino
que además pasa por el punto medio de
efe entonces esta altura es una media
triz df eso está padrísimo porque de
manera similar
tenemos que esta altura tiene estos
ángulos rectos entonces es es una línea
perpendicular a de que pasa por su punto
medio así que es la media actriz y
finalmente tenemos que esta altura es
perpendicular y pasa por el punto medio
así que también es media triz así
logramos convertir las alturas del
triángulo abc en las media trizas del
triángulo de ef y como en df sabemos que
las media tristes concurren entonces las
alturas de abc tienen que
ocurrir vale entonces el argumento está
padrísimo como ya hacemos para ver que
las tres alturas de un triángulo cual
cualquier triángulo concurre bueno pues
simplemente trazamos estas paralelas
construimos el triángulo de ef esas
alturas se transforman en media atrices
y ya sabemos que las media triz es de
cualquier triángulo concurren